- [Instructor] In the last videos,
we saw a dominant Persia
have to put down a rebellion
by the Ionians in the Anatolian Peninsula,
and they were really, really mad
that these Ionians were
helped by the Athenians
and the Eretrians,
and so Darius, the King of Kings goes off
to try to conquer and put down
the Athenians and the Eretrians.
The first time he sends
a fleet in 492 BCE,
it's destroyed by a storm.
And we'll see this is not the last time
that at least part of a Persian fleet
is destroyed by a storm.
Then in 490, he sends a fleet again,
and then he is defeated by the Athenians
at Marathon,
and we saw that right over there.
Let me do that in color
you can actually see.
But as I mentioned in the last video,
the Persians were not done.
Darius would not live to see
another round with the Greeks,
but his successor, Xerxes, would not only
try another attempt, but he
would amass a huge, huge force
against the Greeks to, in his
mind, finally take them over,
and he wants it done so badly
that he leads the forces himself.
And so we are now 10 years after,
10 years after the first Persian invasion.
We are now at 480 BCE, where Xerxes
is going to try to invade
Greece by land and by sea,
but as we will see, he is also
not going to be successful.
But this second invasion
is the stuff of legend,
and once again, the
historical accounts come to us
primarily from Herodotus, who was Greek,
and who was not a direct observer of this.
So you might want to take all
of this with a grain of salt,
because it does make the
Greeks look awfully good.
But we do think that
most of this happened,
but obviously Herodotus probably
added a little bit of bias there.
We are likely to never know.
So let's think about, or let's see
what Xerxes attempts to do.
So we see this magenta line.
This is the line of
attack of Xerxes in 480,
and you can see, there's one magenta line
that is going by sea,
and one magenta line that
is going by sea here,
and another magenta line
that is going by land.
And let's zoom in a little bit more.
I have another map here.
So let's zoom in to
this map right over here
to give us a clearer picture
of what's about to happen
in this next Persian invasion.
So just to reorient ourselves,
here are the land forces,
and according to Herodotus
and historians of that time,
they numbered this force
in potentially millions of soldiers,
modern historians think it
was closer to 50 thousand
to 300 thousand, we really don't know,
but we think it's in the
approximately hundred thousand,
or a few hundred thousands, not millions,
but by any measure, that is a huge,
a huge military force.
So this is hundreds of
thousands right over here.
So hundreds of thousands.
Or let me write this.
Hundreds of thousands, maybe
between 50 and 300 thousand.
They're coming this
way, the Persian forces.
And they also have a fleet
of approximately 1,200 ships.
Now the Persians really
are not having good luck
with weather whenever
they try to attack Greece.
They face a storm, and about a third
of their fleet is destroyed.
And so up here they are left with about,
and these are all approximate,
remember this happened
over 2,000 years ago,
roughly 2,500 years ago,
so it's amazing that we know
anything about it at all,
and obviously we have to rely on Herodotus
and whatever historical
accounts we can find.
So the Persians are
invading by land and sea,
and the Greeks have a strategy of
let's try to stop them
by land at Thermopylae,
and stop them by sea at
the Straight of Artemisium
right over here.
And there is some historical debate of
was this a big, grand
strategy to eventually
try to defeat the Persians at Salamis,
which eventually happens,
or were they generally
trying to stop them there,
and because they couldn't,
they had to retreat back to Salamis.
As we'll see, that second narrative
is what actually happens.
Well I guess in some level,
both of those narratives happen.
That they are able to at
least slow down the Persians
at both of these places, and the Persians
are eventually defeated at
the Straight of Salamis.
Now Thermopylae is the stuff of legends.
It is, if you've ever seen the movie 300,
it is about the 300 Spartan soldiers
led by King Leonitus, along with roughly
7,000 other Greeks that
they're able to collect
to stop the Persians at Thermopylae.
And Thermopylae, you're
in this coastal area
where there's a very limited area for
this massive Persian army
to be funneled through,
and the Greeks are trying to stop them
at the Pass of Thermopylae.
And you can see that right over there.
And, by Herodotus's accounts,
they are actually quite successful
because they are funneling
that Persian army
into a very narrow space,
the Spartans along with the other Greeks
are able to push back.
And this is a massive outnumbering.
Roughly 7,000 versus many
tens or hundreds of thousands,
but as Herodotus's accounts go,
there was a traitor amongst the Greeks
who would go to the Persians
and show them another way around,
and show them another way around.
And so the Persians are
essentially able to,
not only get around the Greeks,
but by surrounding them, are
able to defeat the Greeks
at Thermopylae and continue their march.
And remember, they were able
to get to Eretria before,
10 years before, but
they really want to seek
their revenge on Athens.
And they are able to go to go Athens,
but by the time they go there,
they see that the town has been,
for the most part, evacuated.
That the Athenians, when they saw
that the Persians were coming,
they went to Salamis right over here.
So even though Athens
was sacked and destroyed,
the Athenian people were not destroyed.
Now simultaneous with Thermopylae,
you had a naval battle happen
in the Straight of Artemisium.
And once again, even
though there was about
600 Persian ships that
were in this battle,
there was on the order of
about 200 or 300 Greek ships,
so the Greeks were once again outnumbered,
and they were able to
slow down the Persians,
but not stop them.
And the Persians kept having bad luck,
especially with these storms,
because even we had these
first ships get destroyed,
they sent some 200 ships around Euboea,
I'm probably not pronouncing
it perfectly right here,
but then they get destroyed by a storm.
So now you have the ships
that engaged the Greeks in
the Straight of Artemisium,
the Greeks pull back because
they know they're outnumbered,
and they essentially go in retreat,
or what the Persians think are retreat,
so the Persians follow the Greek fleet
all the way back to the
Straight of Salamis.
And it's over there that
the Greek fleet is able to
plan a defeat of the Persian fleet.
So you have the Persian fleet gets
destroyed decisively at Salamis,
you have the Persian army still in Athens
is able to destroy Athens,
but the Athenian people
have not been destroyed,
and so there's a question for Xerxes,
what to do at this point.
This is all in 480 BCE,
and what Xerxes decides to do,
he says hey I don't want
to get stranded in Europe
at the edge of my empire,
and so Xerxes heads back,
but he leaves some of
his ground forces there,
and they eventually face a
decisive defeat at Plataea,
right over here.
And so that is the last significant threat
of the Persians against the Greeks.
From then there the
Greco-Persian wars continue
for the next several decades,
for the next 20 or 30 years,
but at that point it's more of
the Greeks on the offensive,
and this really is the beginning
of the Golden Age of
the Greek civilization.